dig dig dig come on high five think I
wanna hurt you get one my marbles here
with us today
Marvel casting outside how about that
cuz you knows that how about that
episode a podcast is brought to you by
wink previously Club W is now wink spell
winc wink works directly with winemakers
and growers from all over the world and
creates delicious wine and delivers it
to your front door so if you like wine
check it out and get 20 bucks off when
you go to try wink that's try winc calm
slash Jenna and Julian and they'll even
cover the shipping also this week we
have skin the skin makes it easier for
you to be smarter it's a free email
newsletter delivered to you each morning
with the latest on world news politics
sports entertainment and more all the
information in a readable format right
in your email inbox very helpful very
awesome right now you can sign up at the
skin that's the skin with two M's sk IM
dot-com slash Jenna Julian and you'll be
entered to win a two hundred and fifty
dollar Visa gift card hey thank you
alright
I'm excited to be back
Marvel's here with us he's in his little
sling he loves that which I got I have
like a little backpack for him I've had
multiple like marble carrying devices in
the past this one is probably my
favorite though it's his there too he
loves it looking at he won't get out of
it I was living in his best life right
now okay can you say hello
oh there is they can make a noise and
the mic move the bag a little she loves
that bag so much that he won't even get
out of it - catch me outside how about
tire well but we have some
kind of you know mix of things that
we're gonna talk about today reading and
watching things with my eyes open cuz
I'm like normally you watch things with
your eyes open
generally some people don't I mean it's
probably a whole nother experience know
a couple of these I feel like I've found
out in the last like week or so and one
of them I was sitting on forgot about
and then recently remembered that it
blew my mind but I loved it
are you talking about the EMP or the
Loch Ness thing Loch Ness I had seen and
then forgot about but the EMP EMP thing
is interesting let's start with that
okay it's one of the more plausible or
like realistic Armageddon end of days
sort of scenarios I've ever heard of or
like the end of civilization as we know
it yeah so MP stands for looked
electromagnetic pulse and basically what
it is is it's a device that can
basically just like kill electronics
remotely so if it's near electronics and
it's set off its detonated it will
completely not only turn off the
electronics but it will brick electronic
so we'll turn electronics completely
useless when detonated specifically in
front of those so a little like here's
here's an example so in some of the old
call duty games and I think some of the
newer to college games it's a it's like
a powerup there it's one of those things
when you get a kill streak you can use
an EMP which basically termites really
yeah I was gonna weigh on the podcast to
tell you this because you see you're
trying to MPs and so basically it's like
you know in college or you get kill
streaks you get five kills you get an
airdrop and ten kills whatever you get a
[ __ ] airstrike and then one of the
highest ones is just like you know the
highest amount of kills you can get
probably like ten kills seven or ten
kills is like you get an EMP which
basically turns the enemies team's
electronics completely offline they
don't have radar they're their guns the
sights of their guns don't have the
laser like everything electronic is now
rendered completely off holy [ __ ] yeah
so it's it's been it I mean it's a
tactic in in the military it's been
attacked
in militaries for a lot of years but why
don't you explain why it became
interesting meet you
so it became interesting to me because I
like watching all of the YouTube
channels that describe like the end of
the world and I love every couple years
there will be a new conspiracy about
like why this particular upcoming month
of this particular year is gonna be the
end of the world and here's some random
Disney movie that proves it you know
what I mean
but when I started looking into the idea
that let me just explain it how it was
framed in this video that I watched had
like 63 views on it and it was fire and
I loved it um they frame the scenario
like this so since like the early 80s or
something our government has been very
aware of how easy it would be for
another country that wanted to [ __ ]
destroy America to not have to send over
a nuke or a bomb or have people land
here and fight us and whatever that the
easiest way to destroy our civilization
is to light off an EMP or an
electromagnetic pulse because our power
grid is relatively weak and has not been
updated for a very long time and we deal
with this a lot in California as they do
in New York or other highly populated
areas although those aren't the only
places that are affected by the power
grid being weak that we just happen to
see it a lot because we live in a big
place but its weak as [ __ ] and what I
mean by the power grids weak so that I
mean by the like our actual electricity
like how we get our electricity is very
outdated and old and would cost a lot of
money and a lot of time to update to
make it better so it kind of just is
what it is and I think is not a top
priority for the government if that
makes sense and there's not like a lot
of people being like build this new
power grid we're like dealing with
things that maybe are a little bit more
pertinent at the time yeah I could be
totally wrong or just talking on my ass
but that's what I think something
correct us or it's something that just
isn't on people's main concern because
here in America
electricity is just second nature you
wake up you turn the lights on like you
don't even really think about your
electricity until it's off you know so
this maybe isn't something that people
feel like they need to be concerned
about
so in essence that's the power grid
detonating an EMP would kill the power
grid beyond the point of repair right so
it's our current power grid that the
country is working on the system if it
were destroyed by an EMP would take
years to build back up it would be very
very difficult to build back up because
you don't have electricity while
building the backup right so that's it's
an entry like it's an interesting
thought right the an EMP getting
detonated on such a large scale to the
point where an entire continent mine go
dark well and also in the video that I
watched I was like alright well what is
an EMP like how does someone like go
about doing that apparently they're not
difficult to make and that you can make
them at home that kind of say it's an
electromagnetic pulse and if you you
know do your research it's it's probably
you know for someone who knows what you
know what electrons mean and how to
build them and how they work and how
they interact with other electronics
it's probably a relatively simple
process what my only question would be
is on a scale of an entire continent
right like you know for an EMP to be
detonated within a few hundred yards of
a military base or whatever that's
plausible I get that that's you know it
can send out a pulse and it can just
completely destroy the electronics over
the air but the idea of dropping one or
multiple emps
to knock out a whole country is great I
don't doubt that it's a thing I just
would love to learn more about don't
know how that would happen and I don't
have the answer to that right now and I
know you but I do know from this video
there are some places in the United
States that are protected against and
that you can protect against EMP
like for example Air Force One I believe
has backup or protection against country
because if someone is so here's I guess
the theory if someone were to send off
in the like Isis were like [ __ ] America
we're gonna send off an EMP that Air
Force
no in the air in general and there's
planes in the air and there's everyone
doing things relying on your electronics
you can't like send out a bomb to blow
up the EMP because the MP still then
goes off do you know what I mean yeah so
the only way to actually protect against
something like that is to have like
preventive measures so I do think or
know that there are some things that
have gone that far have that measure but
the vast majority of America on any
level if that were to happen it has no
backup yeah for an EMP yeah which
[ __ ] blew my mind because I always
hear about like zombie or like asteroid
solar flare or a solar flare I think
would there are theories that a certain
type of solar flare on a certain scale
would do something similar to an EMP
okay it's mind blowing but think about
this this is even more mind-blowing so I
was looking through the CIA Declassified
the ones that just got released the 13
million documents that were Declassified
from the Central Intelligence Agency and
I literally looked up EMP because I
wanted to see what was on there
regarding hippies with keywords in the
MPS or whatever and I found this thing
around the time of World War two
basically describing this as a plant
like right if if a country were to want
to wipe out the pair of the power grid
in North America not just the United
States like the North America Peregrine
like the entire continent they were
discussing it as if it was a plausible
option during World War two right right
and now we're in 2017 if you can imagine
the difference in technologies like not
that to me was like whoa right so
seriously well exactly this has been
around for a long time people know that
it exists but I did not know that that
was a thing that was just laws about
threat oh yeah yeah on that scale yeah I
didn't think it was possible and also I
found it very interesting because the
video sort of walked you through the
scenario of what it would be like if an
EMP went off or someone actually did
that and why it's so effective or what
this is just hear me out I need
go back already he likes he described it
as like you're waking up in the morning
and you go downstairs and your wife is
trying to cook breakfast I'm like all
right dude okay but so you know
everything starts off relatively normal
we both are into prepping and being
prepared and having a go bag and stuff
when you live in a place with
earthquakes you know sometimes you don't
know or maybe wherever you live if you
have tornadoes you know what it's like
when you have to prep if some sort of
natural disaster may happen and so you
you prep for you you have like a week or
a month that you know that you could be
okay in certain scenarios right so in
this particular scenario you're like all
right you notice that your lights don't
work and then you realize that your cell
phone doesn't work and your car doesn't
work and obviously your television and
all of that but then at some point
you're running water doesn't work
anymore your gas doesn't work anymore
none of that nothing in your home works
so whatever resources you go through are
now gone and everyone is also out of
their resources you have no power no
nothing and you have no means of
transportation either because your car
is grandpa all electronics everything
with a tiny computer chip in it or a
large computer's head just a completely
bricked and again I mean there's ways to
prevent that or prepping to do that but
in the majority case of people it's not
something that you've ever thought is
just the thought of like liking this is
an inner you wake up one day nothing
happened you didn't see anything you
didn't hear anything right but you wake
up one day and your phone won't turn on
right you're a computer won't turn on
your car won't [ __ ] start right like
things like that
the fact that that isn't like a
apocalyptic fakes they're like that's
something they're gonna happen right so
then they describe the scenario of like
you go outside and there's like your
neighbors out there and everyone's like
talking about how nothing's working and
you know everyone goes back into their
houses and you try to just go about your
day because you can't do anything you
can't communicate with anyone outside of
face-to-face or via letter which I
imagine is not running anymore because
the postal service runs on cars thank
you
computers so there's no way of
communicating with anyone except for
around you so then a couple days go by
and you're like alright are we gonna get
power back like nothing really is
happening people are already starting to
run out of food and start looting and
start robbing either other people's
houses or grocery stores or you know
people start getting panicky and chaos
II maybe after a week two weeks a month
I don't know and then he described that
the first people to die in that scenario
would be people like in hospitals on
life support people that need regular
medications like diabetes if you take
insulin shots and those need to be
refrigerated you can't take your insulin
that those would be the first people
that would die if they don't have the
ability to that insulin cold the elderly
or people that need assistance or help
and then you would see another round of
people dying of just pure starvation or
violent looting or you know people
trying yeah and then the third wave of
deaths which would be pretty dramatic is
just as a result of sanitation so people
can't go to the bathroom and their
toilets because you don't have water
anymore so people are going to the
bathroom outside and like all of these
disgusting diseases are coming through
from just being sick and handling things
and touching things or being outside and
we've already discussed this in the past
I think but the idea that in America or
a lot of countries if a pandemic were to
come through we're relatively unprepared
for that and that a lot of people would
die just due to pure sanitation problems
and being sick and not being able to get
any sort of medical treatment or
anything yeah and that it was like a
statistic that I don't know who came up
with but in this video was saying 9 out
of 10 people couldn't survive an EMP
scenario doomsday scenario they would
throw us into like the Dark Ages and
people like Amish people would be
perfectly fine but everyone else would
be pretty [ __ ] I just I
so interested in the power of a device
that can do something on that still I
just have like I'm skeptical of it I'm
interested in it like you think about
all of the cars that are parked deep
underground in parking lots are
protected by so much metal or or brick
or wood or just thick materials that
generally slow down electric waves right
like whether it's you know for instance
I'm flying my drone and I'm trying to
fly it with a giant brick wall between
me and the drone it's not going to work
because they can't transmit signal
through that material so what I'm
wondering is like you're gonna try to
set our entire continent off the grid
with one or multiple emps how strong how
does that have to be like how is that is
that possible to make something so
strong to the point where like every
single computer electronic in the entire
kondeh is just completely hit by it yeah
that's the biggest is the biggest isn't
for me but I do know that it was
described that our own government had
used this as a tactic in the past I
don't know about you in peace no I don't
know if that's true or not whether it's
true or not they definitely know about
they've used them and I see now I can't
remember but I do remember them
describing it either in some country in
the Middle East and that sounds so
stupid for me to say that but that it
there was record of it being done in
another country multiple times to the
unlike that big scale like like citywide
I mean something on a big scale
happening repeatedly while no one was
talking about it but it was happening
like that's terrifying yeah [ __ ]
crazy as a means of just like destroying
an entire population without having to
do anything well yeah like without
having to do direct violence you know
like bombing or whatever right I mean I
mean imagine a scenario where you you
send off an EMP and then you decide that
you'd also like to bomb that place it's
just like double [ __ ]
it's like you take away all their
resources and everything
survive and then you kill them I meant
yeah that's [ __ ] crazy
right the EMP thought I'm glad you found
this and let's talk about it because for
me it I agree with you a hundred percent
this is the most plausible scenario that
I can find myself believing and in turn
terrifies the [ __ ] out of me right this
is thinking about it as terrifying
because we are so unbelievably crushed
and reliant on our technology so if
that's Nick knocked out from under us
and not only our technology but our
basic electricity our basic human needs
like you said like the plumbing the
electric everyone would be literally
cavemen
but like no one's prepared no one knows
how to survive Amish people do it so I'm
sure we'll dip but you understand 99.99%
of the people would die because they
just didn't know how to survive right
people always say that as if it's like
somehow your fault it would be your
fault if like I guess what I'm trying to
say is like people are like everyone's
gonna die so so rely on our technology
no you'd be an idiot not to be reliant
on your technology at this point but you
you have to at some point give in to
technology because otherwise you can't
advance yourself in this world right
we're already seeing it in terms of when
you go to the DMV at this point you have
to give them your fingerprint in the
state of California they do that like
there are things where you you want no
longer can be like I'm just gonna
[ __ ] chill and not have anything to
do with anything it's becoming more and
more impossible to do that even the DMV
hasn't implemented 90% of the technology
of the day that's like I like to frame
it in the idea that's not necessarily
your fault for being reliant on your
technology yeah it's interesting because
a lot of when you bring up these
scenarios of like doomsday or like being
able to survive without your technology
like there is that general tone of like
only these like fad technology addicted
idiots would just like die off but
really it's like you those idiots are
the ones thriving in this world those
are the people who are doing very well
learning technology advancing with the
mints of Technology and therefore
thriving as a human and whatever and so
I'm a survivalist at this point it would
be a hobby for people yeah and if some
learning how to go do that exactly and
that's honestly it's an issue Bobby but
at the same time it's just that it's a
hobby it's not something that you
require of yourself because at the end
of the day right we don't need it until
we need it right you know and so well I
mean a lot of people are parts of groups
or Boy Scouts or coal Scouts or when
you're a kid and your parents teeth and
it's held it's a healthy hobby I think
it's a good hobby that people should
know that have like basic survival
skills yeah if you were to ask like an
ex-marine I'm sure our survival skills
are nothing compared to what they should
be yeah but I know I honestly do
appreciate that you brought up like you
know not to make fun of or mock the
people who aren't prepared because
they're so addicted to technology like
that's about people's fault that they're
dancing though it's like it doesn't
serve them to not be a dick it's also
like you think about this scenario and
you know that like the general notion of
people without their technology is like
you're useless right you're you're
idiots but no it's like they're smart
it's just when you take away the entire
medium of which they are smart and
proficient in mm-hmm
then they become useless and dumb but
it's it's not for a lack of them being
you know smart on a day-to-day basis I
also just don't like that argument
because whoever the [ __ ] is saying that
all right well then tell me how you get
to work every day without your car
exactly or you travel without an
airplanes like [ __ ] off oh yes you're in
lifting off your high horse
unless you're what's his name on YouTube
that guy making survival videos and even
even he writes in the description of his
videos like I don't live in the woods I
just go out and do this Bobby in my free
time and it's fantastic and really
entertaining to watch
yeah what's the name of that [ __ ]
channel I'm totally blanking on right
now me too
well it'll come to us later in the
process I'd say the worst part about
like the grid going down is not being
able to wake up the next morning and
learning the news from my newsletter
from skin because honestly you don't
have time
mention the money you pay for all the
subscriptions to news sites which a lot
of new sites charging out to read their
their [ __ ] which is annoying so the
easiest way to stay informed is to get
the skin which is an awesome free daily
newsletter that takes all of the top
issues only the important things puts
them into an easy to read email not
convoluted not you have to click around
and click around pop up pop ups it's
it's right there for you easy to read
and you can stay informed
no more bla bla bla it's it's very
to-the-point
very helpful very practical especially
in a doomsday scenario you need the news
you got to check this skin so you guys
can try the skin right now for free you
just go to the skin calm san julian it's
spelled the skin sk IMM there's two M's
calm / san julian you can enter your
email and you click subscribe it's that
simple then you'll start receiving your
emails right from the skin the following
morning there's a lot of stuff to keep
up with in the world and it's
overwhelming but the skin makes it
easier to know what's up its unbiased
fun full of the important things that
you need to know and it's free so check
it out guys really you will not be
disappointed and when you sign up at the
skin calm slots Jenna Julian you will be
entered to win a two hundred and fifty
dollar Visa gift card which is basically
cash so thank you to the skin awesome
stuff there thank you skin also wink I
love that new rebranded name by the way
guys thank you yeah used to be Club W
we've had Club W on a lot they've
rebranded and they are now called wink
winc wink is just an awesome way to get
your wine
personally I've talked about this before
finding wine that I like has been some
of the most difficult shopping moments
I've ever had because you walk up to the
wine aisle and you have no idea what the
[ __ ] you're doing it's like you know the
different you know as Pinot Grigio and
there's South Blanc and you know but
then then there's like a million bottles
and you're like what do I pick how am I
supposed to know what how do I get out
of my current wine thing and stop buying
the same bottle of wine and I'd like to
try some new wine and a leg cake and I'd
like to try to earn that I know won't be
[ __ ] right so what happens is
you don't just get sent random balls
with wink okay week is a personalized
wine membership that recommends wine
specifically for you based on the
results of your palate profile quiz
which is basically they ask you
questions you answer the questions about
tastes that you like and things you like
to eat you know notes of flavor that you
enjoy and don't enjoy and they take that
information and turn it into bottles of
wine so you don't have to pick it by the
coolest wine bottle label you can
actually get wine that you are that's a
choice so what I really used to do I
used to do I used to pick the coolest
looking bottle and let me tell you it is
not recommended way to shop for wine
what is recommended is wink so right now
you guys get 20 bucks off when you go to
try wink that's t ry winc comm slash
Jenna and Julian and they'll even cover
the shipping so check it out thanks
sponsors the name of that YouTube
channel is primitive technology he's
great video yeah because he doesn't post
very often no he doesn't any works for
weeks on his videos so that if you
haven't checked it all by the way very
cool channel out of 10 channel he he
isn't talking all in the description
it's literally of his channel it's like
people I was that's why I don't talk
it's because I learned better by just
watching so I figured I'd make my
channel like that dude he's also in
there's there's very few channels on
YouTube where I'll come across and I'll
just really be like wow I I never knew I
needed this channel but I'm in my life
but I think I need it and I'm so into it
and also what's really cool is he's out
there ok and so it's shot like from him
putting the camera down and then he's
doing it and it's ended and shot in such
a way where it's like very easy to grasp
of what is happening but he also is is
really nice with the shots like it looks
pretty beautiful and and a lot of times
his hands are just so filthy and you're
like how is he moving the camera and
refocusing
and his hands and he's building a hut
out of mud
it's incredible survival [ __ ] all in the
woods it's just a hobby but he if you
ever wanted to learn something he has a
blog as well where you can kind of go
and he's you know I'm just like plugging
the shows having users it's like such a
cool channel anyways well I first of all
as we move on I want you guys to let us
know if any of you have been it deployed
in the military or you have experience
with the MPS in some capacity I'd love
to know more yeah me too
and whatever I said about EMPs you have
to understand that I literally just
found out about this the other day it
blew my mind I knew that's crazy like
what do you think about predictive
programming and stuff like that the fact
that you have little kids playing with
EMPs neither mind blowing doing it was
like I remember it was like there were
like the two of the highest killstreak
rewards one was EMP and the other I
forget but it wasn't some big no hear
your striker right but yeah it's like
because you know how like in the FPV
shooters like you have the the dot on
your site that goes away when the EMP
drops because you can't there's no
electronics so every little thing that's
why I'm just [ __ ] saying
anyway it's also if I were drop knee and
pee on you and you have an airstrike
ready to call in you can't call it even
if you earned it and you have the
detonator you're not allowed to call an
Arab because they can't track it a
bulging I don't they call it do you know
I don't I do I don't to do I don't do
what if we just said I do and I don't
for like the rest 30 minutes that's
terrible it's a terrible podcast what if
that's all we ever podcast and we call
it the I do I don't
podcast and I don't I do
I don't do I don't do all right
a little test drive that see huh oh I
wanted to mention something I totally
forgot what catch me on Sat how about
that Julia that's right alright Loch
Ness monster yes okay so I watched this
a while ago you were like I forget where
you were you were out with like a friend
or something and I was staying in that
and I alone drinking wine and watching I
believe I was watching in search of
aliens which was Giorgio tsoukalos from
ancient aliens with the hair the guy
aliens that mean it's his like spin-off
show called in search of aliens which I
believe only has one season and it came
out a couple years ago or something and
so I was like well I better watch all of
this you and your Giorgio I love Giorgio
so I think it was episode three where
they talk about the Loch Ness monster
don't read this much you know I'm
literally not even reading so i i i
don't know about you guys but like for
the Loch Ness monster Bigfoot you know
that kind of thing so some of the more
traditional conspiracy theories I felt
like a Ness monster or a Bigfoot I felt
like I had a really solid grasp of all
of the theories that were out there so
really quick
what was your grasp previously of the
Loch Ness monster what did you think
like when you thought of Loch Ness
monster before you read this what was it
in your mind well I mean was the same as
Bigfoot like sightings happen all the
time no one's been able to prove or
disprove it and what it's underwater
right yeah it's underwater just in case
people are just buzzers I'm just saying
like everybody there's you know what
Tommy out there I know you don't know
what it is and I don't want to put you
on the spot little Tommy he's like 16
mm-hmm Tommy don't get mad that I called
you out
I just want everyone to know we're
talking about whatever so I had never
heard this theory about the Loch Ness
monster before in a [ __ ] kind of
blowing my mind a little bit let's get
on with it all right so in order to
understand this you might need to
understand some other things first I'm
not good at that
okay well Julian you've watched enough
Asian aliens right mm-hmm
I mean most of the time but I've watched
yeah so maybe the view yeah for anyone
that doesn't know which I don't know how
you listen to this podcast and not know
but Giorgio tsoukalos has a show called
the ancient aliens the entire theory is
basically that aliens have been visiting
planet Earth since forever and that were
conscious
yes what people perceive as gods have
always just been extraterrestrials
helping us at the terrestrials have been
helping us with technology and that sort
of thing so like our ancestors weren't
lying when they were like the gods came
down from the sky and gave us this book
about how we should live they're like no
that's true it was probably an alien and
like they go through like cave walls of
like the paintings and they're like
they're depicting aliens in space yes so
that's the whole show is ancient aliens
but well I'm they in the first season
and most of the other seasons after that
they spend a lot of time in like places
where there's old structures like
ancient Egypt where there's pyramids and
obelisks and all of these old [ __ ]
things and there's those pyramids all
over the world they happen everywhere so
there's so many good theories it's a
great [ __ ] show and it's funny you
might laugh some of its over the top a
lot of it is the reaching to end all
reaching but it's fun and fascinating
and entertaining and I'm happy exists so
in Egypt they make this argument a lot
that because there's a high
concentration of quartz in some of these
things and around the world but they're
they theorized that quartz under stress
can create electromagnetic fields which
can be quar diseases like the stone yeah
which is why it's used to build a lot of
these things and they theorized you know
the pyramids are like actually energy
conductors and like they are beamed up
into space or someone's using them to
create power on earth you know whatever
there's all kinds of different theories
but I had never heard of the quartz
electromagnetic field theory when it
came to the Loch Ness monster so listen
to this because they they did the same
thing in Lake Champlain and of course
take all of this with a grain of salt
so Loch Ness has a high presence of
quartz in it and it's like it in the
show I can't remember is a long time ago
I was [ __ ] drinking wine it didn't
have time to rewrite it for this podcast
every wink line because I think you
sorry
they were saying that because it's like
relatively narrow but very deep and also
has a high presence of quartz that it
could in theory in a very stretchy
Theory create an electromagnetic field
in side of the lake so that when people
see the Loch Ness monster the quartz has
actually created a wormhole through time
where the Loch Ness monster is just sort
of coming through that wormhole at that
moment or just passing through right
because the way that the courts would be
affected it could affect the structure
of the space-time continuum
like on the quantum level do you see
this angle you like just really squint
your eyes and expand your mind every
once in a while when the quartz gets
stretched like stress underneath the
earth inside of the lake it could in
theory create a wormhole that which
would explain why when people go out
there and they're looking for it's not
there we can't find it on our little
fish readers or we're looking in the
bottom of the lake and why do people see
it sometimes where does it go yeah this
theory would make it so just about
everyone is correct yes you've seen Loch
Ness the Loch Ness monster and the
people that sit there for years and
years and claim to have seen it you may
have seen it because it might have been
a stress in the space-time continuum
where the Loch Ness monster like imagine
your Loch Ness monster right so it's
like a prehistoric dinosaur swimming in
the water and then it accidentally
sometimes crosses through a wormhole
which brings it to now right but then it
would go back when the wormhole is no
longer there so the other compelling
part of this was that there's Lake
Champlain which I think is in New Jersey
where is it I should look it up I feel
dumb that I don't always have all my
education that they have similar
sightings of a similar creature called
champ and the lake guess what has in it
all right levels the courts [ __ ]
and it's very narrow and very deep just
like Loch Ness
hello so I want to know the quartz thing
when it creates like my electromagnetic
fields is that something that's been
scientifically proven and tested bunch
or is it just like you know I don't have
the answer to that and if I did it would
take all the fun out of this it's in
Vermont with everything the claims on
even a website that's super crazy out
there
would have to be backed up by some sort
of semblance of science where courts
being compressed or whatever under
pressure would create electromagnetic of
some sort there has to be some sort of
real nugget of truth and and tested you
know experiment experimenting with with
it at some point or maybe there isn't
but I honestly think that if someone's
gonna make a theory like that there had
been some sort of test so I'd love to
look more into the actual science of
quartz and electromagnetic fields before
I started looking deeper into this
theory do you want me to look up real
quick sure it's Kermit crying yeah do
you need some courts if I put courts in
your bed all right Loch Ness monster in
your bed
I looked up courts electromagnetic
energy and the first thing that came up
is from October 12 2014 the mind
Unleashed it says science finally
catching up to what the ancients already
knew about crystals
despite the plethora of anecdotal
evidence that exists on the healing
powers of stones and crystals the debate
continues to rage in the scientific
community over whether crystals actually
have any real healing power basic
internet search reveals many articles
claiming crystal healing to be
pseudoscience in fact one recent study
argues that crystals have absolutely no
healing power and the placebo effect
amounts for most people's healing
experiences with them based off of the
electromagnetic fields like it does
sound debate it sounds well that
obviously but I mean the negative
effects oh we should have a podcast
where we just googled fit on the podcast
that's pretty lit quartz page physical
properties look in this this looks
shifty
this looks far more scientific than
whatever I just read buzz
light light can be described as an
oscillating electromagnetic field that
propagates through space as a wave I
don't need to know about what light does
I would like to know about quartz
alright when we can't do this right now
I'm not gonna find you need to come back
and do part two we need to do some
hardcore research on the quartz thing
when but let's table the quartz we can
but I think that's part of like the
whole engine alien thing is like we can
only theorize what these giant like
monoliths made out of quartz could be
used for because I don't think that we
have completely understood or understand
some of the properties of what might
make this work do you know I'm saying
absolutely when it's theorized that the
pyramids of Egypt they're shaped like a
Ryan they're like perfectly organized
like in a line with the sky yes no idea
oh okay
or like you know some of the obelisks
and things like if you were to run an
electric current through that like what
what that would happen or there's like a
another place that's shaped exactly like
a [ __ ] computer chip so yeah so like
maybe we don't know the answer to that
maybe I'm wrong here but yeah as far as
I'm concerned it's only ever theorized
that quartz has this property and I
don't know there's probably a nugget of
science and then all debated other stuff
I love that that's great science and
then a [ __ ] wild and free imaginative
conversation about what not otherwise
how are you gonna bend your mind if it's
just all scientific facts you can't
debate anything and so you can't even
expand that's like my dad well your dad
is a material science engineer no no
he's the chemist chemist your brother's
material science yes so I remember like
when I first started getting like really
into like questionable things and I was
I asked my dad about like string theory
and stuff and he was sort of just like
he would laugh and then give you like a
really straightforward answer like
nothing that you're looking for was I'm
saying with my brother too like you'll
say something and he'll just be like
yeah
just for a second when I was growing up
or even today if I talk if I ask my
grandpa like about Adams because he
works at a linear accelerator Stanford
Linear Accelerator like one of the
biggest in the world he works there and
has worked there for years so anytime I
have a question like what about quantum
physics and I'm like where she's like -
huh math nerd yeah but it's not like in
a fun way it's like they have the answer
already that already negates everything
that you just were interested in yeah
it's like shutting down your creativity
with their backs [ __ ] genius
you know fun yeah that's crazy well I
think I definitely do I like that I like
this the lot I like it and I would love
to get back and do some research
specifically on the quartz thing see
what's out there and maybe you can come
back and sort of do a part to follow up
on okay because it's to me that's like
super [ __ ] interesting well I was
like it's very rare in my low level of
expertise of conspiracy theories that
you find a solution that literally makes
it so that everyone is right you don't I
mean like that everyone that has
theorized about that you know where does
it go where is it really there like
everyone's pretty much right well they
leave passing through wormholes so it's
only briefly in our time makes perfect
sense that one only sees it for a second
right so it's like you're right it's
proving all these sightings as fickle as
they may sound to be perfect like those
two lakes in particular because of their
high level of quartz and like ability to
have stress and in this certain shape I
don't have to go back and watch it it
creates sort of like the perfect
environment to create a wormhole but
there's also theories about that being
the case for you know what if that's the
case for a Bigfoot or the case for all
the Megalodon or whatever those giant
sharks are sightings or whatever
recently like maybe these things are
real but they're sort of just passing
through the space-time continuum for the
moment that you've seen them and then
they're gone that's crazy
it's not amazing yeah yeah I like it
I like
if you also think about it in terms of
like the Bermuda Triangle or you have
these places where we don't know much
about them but they are sort of portals
or something something of this because
it's because I'm traded energy of some
sort they go and then they never come
back
so like planes go through them yeah yeah
yeah and they disappear so if you can
you should look on the CIA Declassified
on that too sure it's like if you can't
find the wreckage of a plane and it's
just vanished who's to say that it
didn't just go through and do it right
on a like a wormhole like can you or
like if so say you're an ancient people
on earth and maybe some airplane comes
down and crashes down through a wormhole
because they went through the Bermuda
Triangle I'm pretty sure that I'd be
like holy [ __ ] these are our gods
meanwhile in today's world on ancient
aliens we're watching a story about how
millions of years ago they found an
airplane part we're like wait a minute
it just went through a wormhole
okay that's what's crazy or like when
aliens come here they're really just
like maybe getting lost in another
universe the travel tree of a wormhole
and they're not here to do anything
other than be like oh [ __ ] we're [ __ ]
really lost right now yeah I'm like
that's crazy well that would explain why
there's all different types and kinds of
UFO sightings because maybe they're all
were like really really different places
crazy futuristic yeah totally different
and like somebody went through a wrong
wormhole and they were like oh [ __ ]
we're [ __ ] or anything I filmed in the
sky I might have been coming through a
wormhole no that was a Trident to
missile that's what they said it was a
trident ii missiles sounds like that's
what they want you to believe I do
believe it and it was a Trident to
missile you call a sheep just saying one
sheep I think I think the intentions of
that tried into missile this is very for
debate because they lit it over and they
like flew it over this second largest
city in the United States
t he don't mind us we're just the
military over here testing our Trident
to miss an idea I played right into
their hand I did exactly what they
wanted they were
someone to film it I did it I'm just I'm
a government prop the last thing that I
wanted to talk about yeah which was
another thing that I learned about for
the very first time ever never heard of
it which blew my mind was Zozo so I like
this like i-i've never heard anyone talk
about if anyone has is probably Shane
Dawson and I don't [ __ ] with Ouija
boards they really scare me I use soon I
was younger and we used to play a game
called psychic circle which was really
fun but I don't [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
anymore because legitimately terrifies
me good but there's a worldwide
phenomenon called Zozo or Zaza or mama
which is like a people theorizes a
darker demonic entity that comes and
like sabotages your Ouija board base so
one of the examples was someone was
talking or heard from Zozo that they
like how am I gonna die in this also
said yeah go ahead I wanted to give more
of a battery so people would describe
and this is cross-culturally across the
world this has been reported many many
many times tens hundreds that's why
don't you look it up right now because I
don't remember but yeah so people will
be playing their Ouija board and
thinking that they're talking to a
spirit or you know a little boy and the
thing with demons or evil entities is
that don't Google Zozo demon oh there's
a weird picture that comes up and I
don't like crowds okay is that demons
and evil spirits don't play by any rules
like if they want to trick you and lie
to you they will because it sounds right
so there's a lot of examples of people
saying like hey listen I'm listening I
just don't like it the people would be
like I thought we had sat down as a
group of friends to talk to you know a
dead family member or a loved one and
they would ask you questions to make
sure that it really is then like
something that only you know your past
grandmother would know yeah so you know
we're sitting here
we're being like alright what color was
grandma's favorite flower
or something like that and it would tell
you and you were like oh amazing alright
we're talking to my grandma right now
and then people would report it just all
of a sudden making figure eights
or circles many times in a row and then
telling you that it's Jose o zo zo or za
za or ma ma over and over and over again
so there's also a conspiracy theory or
pull on me finish so when people would
be like who is us who is Zozo who is
Zaza who is this they would reveal to
you that they were pretending to be your
dead grandmother and the reason they
knew those answers was because they were
reading your mind yeah isn't that fun
yeah I don't like that and then of
course there's all the people being like
it's if like took over me for a minute
and it felt hot and I had really bad
luck but like why is there a cross
cultural phenomenon of some of the same
spirit or entity like just sort of
invading people's Ouija boards what do
you mean why if you believe in demon
spirits and that's why it's a demon
spirit it's so crazy
there's another conspiracy theory that
it's sort of a Ouija trick so you're
never supposed to go backwards on the
alphabet or the numbers because that
could open the portal and let someone in
so the physical spelling of the word
Zozo like forces you to go back and
forth back backwards over and over again
on the board which opens like a demonic
portal god damn I'm like genuinely
freaked out right now
isn't it [ __ ] I don't like this yes so
people please don't ever try to contact
those elders awesome don't tell it that
we [ __ ] up in fact if you could put in
a good word with up for me I love it you
might want to like actually watch some
of those like videos or read some about
it because it's it's a real thing that
people are just like [ __ ] people up
yeah it's not cool I don't know if you
believe in that or don't believe in that
but I wholeheartedly believe in that
[ __ ] okay what I'm good no I'm good
you're good what I'm good like I have
nothing to participate I'm like
it's it's a it's like I believe in it
but I feel like the more I talk about it
the more I'm gonna psych myself out and
that should happen to me okay doing
we'll stop talking about it but if
you're interested in it there's a lot of
I'm like freaked out that's it like I
don't know like I never want to sit here
and be like it's stupid why did you
believe you know because then I feel
like that is gonna just bring it or you
know I don't know the more words I say
the more I stick myself out if you have
any personal experiences with that
phenomenon please tell us in the
comments but also it said like some of
the warning signs were it going to the
four corners of the board or creating
figure eights or circles over and over
again but it's just crazy to me that any
sort of entity could trick you into
moving the the thing on the board so
that it could vote yeah for certain acts
all right like demon spirits and demons
like Masters of Deception exception yeah
so it's like I mean it's terrifying but
that makes perfect sense anything about
yeah so fast you hear that noise
no it's Kermit at the door yeah he's
kind of Zoey if you're interested in it
you can look up stuff on it
I wouldn't recommend doing it I haven't
I have yet to read anything positive
about that experience so please don't
I'm just gonna have a bad time I'm gonna
stick with the courts for now I'm good
with courts maybe after a couple bottles
of wink I know yeah so those were the
interesting things interesting that I
came across this this week's rain
strange things change things that's
dangerous to do to to to to to almost
like that song alright guys thank you so
much for joining us for another podcast
even though I got scared at the end I
leave with some good comments about
their information you know
I know there's a lot of you every one of
you guys I know is smart but in
different ways so if you guys have any
knowledge of the MPs or anything that we
talked about feel free to let us know in
the comments quarries electromagnetic
field yes all that stuff we would love
to know more we were also probably like
I said get a follow up at some point and
do a part two about that but thank you
guys for listening this talk oh yeah I
wanted to probably wrongdoing